good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 1342 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures SCP 1342 is to be stored at
site 15 SCP 1342 1 is to be kept within
a Faraday cage measuring 15 by 15 by 20
meters to prevent transmission of
telemetry and other data regarding SCP
1342 SCP 1342 2 is to be stored in a
standard electronic components Locker 1
decoded copy of SCP 1342 2 is to be
contained in a separate Locker
in addition monitoring of Gliese 445 by
radio telescope is to be conducted as
SCP 1342 3 is unlikely to be containable
in the near future project Heimdall is
to continue in its contingency planning
operation description SCP 1342 1 is a
replica of Voyager 1 exact replication
of the original probe extends to sensor
packages and apparent chemical
composition however some components
appear to have been constructed based on
incomplete plans or parts as a result
several components were non-functional
upon recovery SCP 1342 1 was initially
detected on September 25th 1982
approximately 35,000 kilometers above
the Earth's surface traveling in a sub
orbital velocity foundation agents
recovered as CP 1342 1 on September 27th
1982 after SCP 1342 1 underwent an
uncontrolled atmospheric entry and
splashdown 300 kilometers east of Baker
Island Pacific Ocean SCP 1342 one's
detection was possible due to a large
burst
of Cherenkov radiation that occurred
upon its appearance it is currently
unknown how a CP 1342 one remained
intact during its descent despite
appearing to have a similar chemical
composition to the original voyager SCP
1342 2 is a gold-plated phonograph
record with specifications matching the
golden records carried on the Voyager
probes instructions for playing and
decoding remain original however the
pulsar map has been altered to show the
star Gliese 445 as the origin of SCP 13
42 when decoded SCP 13 42 2 contains a
variety of cultural and scientific data
in the forms of images and audio
approximately 2 hours of audio
recordings are present consisting of
various forms of music and atonal
buzzing part of the music appears to be
an excerpt of Cavatina from the string
quartet number 13 and b-flat opus 135 8
holdin the encoded images vary greatly
in content but all contain physical or
chemical information on the subject for
example size mass and orbital period of
a planet and a string of pictorial
characters a radially symmetric organism
referred to as SCP 1342 3 is shown in
various stages of development
fully-grown the organism is
approximately 2 meters tall and has
three legs and three elongated arms with
each hand having three fingers
positioned around the central axis on a
roughly cylindrical torso
3 snout like protrusions exists in place
of a head each ending in a beak 82% of
these encoded images show SCP 1342 3 in
a wide variety of presumed cultural
settings
scenes identified include agriculture
manufacturing urban crowds and the
playing of music on a string and bow
instrument
images of a number of celestial bodies
are also included such as a Venusian
type world with a high atmospheric
pressure and a star matching Gliese 445
stellar spectra one planet has a
partially earth-like surface consisting
of approximately 60% liquid water 4%
urbanisation and plant life and 36%
apparent desert and wasteland the planet
has larger than expected storms and ice
caps than would be suggested by physical
quantities supplied by a CP 1342 - and
appears to be undergoing massive
ecological collapse an outline of
specimen 1342 3 is shown next to this
planet this planet is shown to have
extensive orbital infrastructure not
limited to spacecraft manufacturing
facilities captured asteroid mining
operations and space elevators grounded
near urbanized in wasteland areas all of
these images show the structures to be
in a wrecked or neglected state the
final encoded image shows a vessel
heading towards an extremely damaged
Taurus style Space Station with a 2
kilometer diameter aperture at its
center documents 1 through 56 the
following message was encoded on SCP
1342 2 in 55 different languages
matching the 55 in which audio greetings
were sent on the original Voyager and is
consistent in all the 56th document is
entirely composed of pictorial strings
and this is the English version of SCP
13 42 two's message
this Voyager spacecraft was built in the
year forty two thousand four hundred
twelve eighty by the species you come to
refer to as the collision we are a
community of three hundred thousand
beings inhabiting Gliese 445 C this is
our message to your world
ever since we discovered radio we have
lived in your shadow decades were spent
unraveling your signals searching for
answers among the tenuous strands of
reason through static in the chaos we
found you from your small distant walled
we found your images your music your
thoughts your feelings and your
indomitable science we communicated with
your world's governments who kept our
existence secret from you to prevent any
culture shock with their own populace I
want to reduce your impact upon our own
species it did not matter to us we could
touch the mind of another and now we are
not alone we learned from you the
Scientific Revolution following our
meeting was miraculous we lift beyond
our natural years and we lived well
humans have lifted us to analyse Ian's
state but we could never thank you from
our faraway place we quietly deciphered
your secrets another time our technology
became your equal together we went and
trancing our mastery of the universe we
shed our technology with your ladies in
secret to try and repay you for all you
will do in time came the gates at great
expense of energy we could obtain
limitless velocity with time dilation
reserve we could fly to the universe's
path and its death the entirety of
creation was within our mutual grasp
however that would not be before we
emerged the people who live on your
planet crippled us from the sky above in
bright blue flashes our lives were ended
we did not know their reasons nor do we
know why the hand was stayed enough to
forestall our extinction but now we live
on a dying world our children are sick
our water is polluted we can only attain
our technology we will not go on to save
ourselves we could have tried to destroy
you it cannot be denied that that is how
some of us felt we should act we could
still hear your world unknowing uncaring
with what little power we had left
relativistic destruction could reduce
your planet to ashes as it was forming
it is shaming but we came so close we
hope you can understand why we thought
what we did but maybe if we could change
what happens if we could destroy you
then you could save us from the stars
came the light you your gift in sending
your message filled with your music and
your joy you showed such touching
desperation to find another we fell in
love all over again
we have but one chance to put things
right I do not know if you can save us I
do not know if you can change who you
one day maybe you say you were trying to
survive through your time so you may
live into mine I really hope that you
you do
but above all else there is one thing
you need to know from one maker of music
to another across all worlds all things
no matter what you do I'll not ever come
you are nothing less and beautiful wow
it's kind of moving right man Steven
Spielberg got it wrong anyway thank you
for listening if indeed you still are
and you were all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to the reclusive extrovert geum's Saba
Katherine June's Pablo ice 917 Kareem a
la shmoop
Justin de Pury kuma trevor w peg white
crew and jayvo Jack Bryson Bailey my
archive curator neck tie verbal
Burlington the cot and courts 563 if you
would like a special thank you at the
end of each of my videos on some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the Volgin thank you
[Music]
you